come on Adam versus Adam Oh bad move bro
[Music]
good name though Adam
hello how the devil hi today we're
playing a new battle royale game which
is part PvE part PvP but we'll get to
that in a moment this is bad blood it's
dying light spinoff series they're going
to make this completely free to play on
all platforms but at the moment it's in
closed beta which is going to open up to
everyone very soon so we are playing on
the PC at the moment because that's the
only format it's available in at present
and we can't put PlayStation button
prompts on the screen it has to be Xbox
ones so when it says press X and I don't
press the correct button it's because
I'm using a PlayStation controller and I
have no idea where X is on an Xbox
controller so if you're ready let's do
this okay so what's the premise to this
game what we need to do we're going to
be thrown from the sky we're going to
hit down hard our first job is to find
weapons and things to use in battle so
we can survive from that point it's
about trying to locate these piles of
goo which are samples which we need to
extract because if we're going to get
off this island it's going to be on the
helicopter and we have to earn our place
these piles of goo are protected by a
zombie horde some are bosses which are
big buggers which are very hard to take
down
others are a little bit more simple use
cut their heads off and whilst all this
is happening there's another 11 players
who can come and kill you at any point
and take your samples so they can earn a
seat on the helicopter which is
activated at level 5 oh don't worry if
you didn't get all this it comes pretty
easily anyway when you get to the
helicopter you must kill anyone who's
there because the helicopter will not
land until there is only one person
standing that's the premise can we win
it let's do this
right we need to find weaponry first
always find a weapon sighs my favorite
weapons right away this is good this is
good we can mod these weapons and so if
we try and find it one of the mod packs
I'll show you how it works
maybe in here Soviet sickle no we don't
want one of those hey DIY grenade that's
good and our rolls yes we're always
going to pick up our arrows because they
stick in people's bodies so they have to
literally take them out of their body to
stop bleeding effects same with these
same with throwing axes so if we're up
against someone we're going to try and
shove something in their face and stab
them as hard as we can oh my word we
have a bow this is good we are quite set
now this is pretty damn good
click it back here we go
this is a bleed upgrade so I can apply
it to my scythe so when I hit someone
now they will bleed for longer you know
what I think we think we ready to rock
and roll
so let's go try and find our first
sample on the left-hand side of the
screen can you see where it says 2 2 2
those are the top three people in the
server in the lobby who were who are
going to go for the hill look at it look
at this I get back that in a moment
right here are zombies protecting that
high and we can get it going there's a
guy how do we get the hypernova going
for him did you see some his name
yes we're playing on PC there are people
called cyka blyat sure you know what
that means already come on boy come on
boy
face me mano a mano lucky look at that
name right he has a riot shield that's
good that's really good for us this riot
shield can be just held in front of us
so we can stop people hitting us really
useful especially against zombie hordes
right we need to go back and take that
hive sample so we can level up
speaking of leveling up I'm a level one
at the moment if I get up to level 2 by
picking up those samples my damage
output goes off and it also completely
heals me so at the moment I have 85
health so hopefully will this get us up
to level 2 it does and now I have 110
health pretty good pretty cool how it
works anything to take
the noise run away
is he gonna come let's track him down
the the color of the weaponry is how
legendary it is how exotic how difficult
it is to find but I really like the size
it doesn't have any fantastic outputs of
damage it's just fun to use on mine and
a Molotov yeah you'll burn more throwing
axes so just behind this bus is another
high which we shall take nobody else got
fast little to get on the bloody bus man
I hit the thank you
he's fighting someone
I think someone's there there is I can
hear someone there is someone near us
oh and these aeroplanes are coming in
how air drops in which will get today
the moment let me just hide for a second
try to flank him let's see if the sound
of footsteps are easy to follow two of
the people are now up to level three so
they will hit even harder now so their
damage will be ridiculous
so this stops people from just camping
you need to get involved too - or look
at this is gonna explode it's gonna be
cool yeah you can completely annihilate
someone who is doing a really good piece
of work he has taken down probably five
or six zombies there and I'm taking all
the samples all his hard work
I think his samples - and now on the top
left corner we are winning so we need to
get to level five whoever gets to level
five first will call in the helicopter
but don't worry if we can't call in the
helicopter ourselves we can get to the
landing site and kill everyone else to
take their samples and therefore take
their place on the helicopter simple as
Peas
to do all this parkour on the controller
all I'm doing is a tapping lr1 apologies
one air monitor for you gas
my
you want move move forward the amount of
times I've killed myself on this game
with landmines she'll be surprised and
you'd need I was an adventurer like you
once yeah he's done yeah let's get that
right these bigger enemies such as these
spitters will also drop armor so the
blue bar at the bottom that's my armor
in addition to my health which is on top
oh shoot I told you I told you I get
myself oh I told you I get myself with
landmines all the time so this should
get us up to rank for same as cast spell
so there's two of us this is a decent
game so far right on the mini-map you'll
see these little blue icons and these
weapon drops which are protected by
these little you can throw them that's
cool if you press dodge or block at the
right time which is l1 on the controller
try again you can throw them the
opposite direction then go to town on
this goal don't get up bro don't do it
man your friend is watching your friends
does not want part of this what have you
got for me
hey dude
throw and then we'll go to town on a
space yeah that's ridiculously
satisfying okay so this first enemy
dropped some more armor which is good
and not this one the blue one should
have a weapon inside which should let us
win the game we do a hunting rifle and
some health that's really good
Oh whilst we've been doing this castle
if you look on the top left on earth
someone has called in the helicopter and
he can get on it so we have to
absolutely bucket now 300 meters or
don't think there's enough time we'll
give it a go see what happens
I've got a packer all the way there and
hopefully we can steal his loot take his
samples and steal his slots on the
chopper
so as Arnie would say come on do it get
to the chopper I love the parkour so
cool
and the music builds thank you
100 meters away we're gonna get the
house sugar I took damage then it's okay
oh there's somebody up there
50 meters away so there's me vs. castle
versus I am Rasputin so this is a
three-way
right I'm here he can't believe ha ha in
your face my ball I got a gun you bring
a knife to a gunfight dude you'll be
gone what you got for me some poles now
I can get on the helicopter so can that
Cass poor guy who's on his way down soon
40 meters away come on bro let's do this
- - left just two of his left even if he
doesn't get in here in at six seconds
five seconds I will automatically win
he's in with a second to go
he's walk straight into my landmines
come on Brock let's do this rule on mine
at me come on I'm an adventurer
I have accurately see if you like a
blind man come on dudes
so my heavy breathing there was because
my character my character stamina is
quite low so you have to take a second
out of fighting so you can't just go in
and wail on them you have to think about
your stamina come on dude what you got
this is tense isn't it this is tense
right there opening - ah miss let up
so you see because I have a bleed effect
on my side he had to pull out than one
of the barbs to stop his his health from
depleting well this is tense scene one
day supply so I was trying to heal there
didn't go well for me so again he has to
pull that barbell there he goes
come on who's gonna make the first move
I went to another one mine this is good
this is great for us you know I'm going
to heal Hey just one hit one hit sorry
take there's the kick there's a slice
best to jump you're the [ __ ] that's how
it's done
what do you think dying light bad blood
I won't lie that was freaking brilliant
I really enjoyed that GG's in chats that
was really fun really fun so it's coming
soon hopefully there will be an open
beta for all consoles as well as PC but
keep in mind this will be free-to-play
we can all play this together very soon
and we got victory and we have an s-rank
for the players kill there's only 11 so
far is okay we managed to get take down
three hives and we have 1,800 samples
not bad at all
what's appear
it's two people scrapping one person
just what the heck get there man
I do but guard oh come on I got this
I've got this stop running away
come fight me bro nice hear you bees
gone next
nice would you like something from this
pile of goodies okay oh you got the
shield god damn it
all right come on I have my katana for
your face Adam nice name get out bloody
shield I need to get him down so we can
jump trying to get him from the sky come
on Adam versus Adam Oh bad move bro good
name though Adam so we'll try and take
down this hive where the hell is the
hive
I've where are you serious
[Music]
there's a spitter some way it's a
spitter somewhere dude don't spit
swallow come round to see you miss
katana is so cool
if I could hit anything with it hey go
bro I do parkour losing hit him so hard
he is completely combusted into oblivion
and now we pick up the goodies tense
this is tense I cannot be picked up by
the helicopter I'm only level 3 so I
have to kill log E and typicalgamer hey
dude nice to see typical gamer nice to
meet you sir I do parkour let's go yeah
the riot shield is so good for defending
I'll try and show you come on
that was terrible Adam three more bring
them close slice them both hit slices it
dices and Michonne Michonne
I'll put you out of your misery you
don't mean that I'm you don't need that
head I love these landings right lute up
as quick as possible my pink gloves very
camp very me we have an ice upgrade so
that will slow people down if we put it
on a weapon
good old shield what's this more
landmines look you want some takeaway
not some brains takeaway mmm
dee Powell I'm behind you dude
still this I've got the power oh thank
you for all your hard work I will take
everything from you I will finish your
work as well take this goon let's do
this bro
dodge dodge and weave dip duck duck
ducks and dick and duck and ducks if you
can dodge a sledge hammer you can dodge
a dodge ball oh we got this yeah boy get
an answer samples galore we should be
able to call in the heli chopper soon
yeah yeah no not yet still level four
I'm so confused
come on dude he's got a gun right hello
everybody I have a land mine boy any
survivors we shall face off what did you
throw at me
what are you poor Nolan mine we are not
going to get through this but we'll take
him down with us we have fourteen health
it's a good dodge gone no yeah so the
account encounters are much more slower
than you'd expect
stop talking sorry I can't talk and play
at the same time come on
how did we get out of that with three
health we're gonna win this game
this is our game express delivery I do
enjoy that did anyone survive I love it
I'm sorry everyone I shall put you all
out of your misery and I shall take the
goodies Oh his head bounced off the
table
wow this is epic I'm really enjoying
this hmm I think we're safe to go kick
in the face must add some wrestling
moves to this we need epic leg drop
cornered you didn't really well in your
back that's how we roll let's try old
bow and arrow
I'm an adventurer let's look at arrow to
the knee I don't know there arrow to the
knee are these right we're going to try
and take that weapon from them these
these are pretty these gents are pretty
good at avoiding attacks and then they
team up on you so it's not easy to take
these down conical edge two zombies and
I have backed myself into a corner like
an idiot you want to kick in fright dear
Dave there's somebody else here oh no
it's not gonna go well we have to get
out of this corner we have to die okay
okay we need to find a way around we've
got one hit in us something to throw
something to heal oh here we go upgrade
for the size the side now how has a
shock damage so there was a stutter for
a while afterwards someone killed
Benjamin Franklin come on was ticking
shucks show come on Chuck show Lisa five
it's a fact
come back here bro he must have like
three or four health come on sample I'll
take something thank you come on Chuck
show let's finish this like men
mano-a-mano
man to man where the hell has he gone
[ __ ] balls
we shall meet again brother in this life
or the next
[Music]
someone leo has called in the helicopter
we've got to get to it come on do it
who's this Oh shucks joke we meet again
I knew we would he has a gun he hasn't
even got a chance
she's crazy me more like oh oh we got
lucky there we need to find his gun that
will win us the game hunting rifle
hunting shotgun yeah where should we put
it oh there's no bloody ammo oh well at
least now we can get on the helicopter
too
I think it's three of us left Leo versus
an amaru versus child in the fog Paco
all the way to the helicopter no don't
go and kill yourself
sneaking behind the plan is to sneak
behind
we're here 24 seconds can we hide down
here 22 no that's a shame
so we have to be up here find a hiding
spot this you can be the bush working so
baby boys too icky who is that wrong
I'll let you see what happens okay Leo
I'm going to steal your helicopter six
five we got this in the bag
we're not even gonna have to fight is
here is Leo lost child in the fog take
him down in one hit from death
Leo moves in Leo takes the kill this is
it one on one that's gonna win this
operate super and amaru Oh buddy has a
defensive shield what's gonna it has a
bulb
oh I don't you can't hit what you can't
see what's next
can I Oh terrible aim I can pretend I
have a shotgun
they won't come near me yeah I got a
shotgun there's no bullets inside but I
do have a shotgun Leo your defensive
player I see I'm coming to get you mofo
you were evacuated we survived
we've run away we live to fight another
day we got to the chopper that is a nice
suit damn Daniel
what do you think anyway downlight I am
really enjoying this game there's a few
tweaks that need to be made the the
stamina meter doesn't always add up some
of the damage outputs are a bit skew
whiff but this is just the closed beta
which will become an open beta soon and
I think it's going into early access on
PC which means there may be a little bit
more to wait for on console but as soon
as we know anymore
I will definitely be back again what do
you think to this anyway would you like
to see more of this game or should I go
back to fortnight I imagine from
PlayStation granade it's been a bloody
pleasure I'll see you next time